we begin this newshour with breaking
news out of burkina faso where an
attempted coup is underway reports from
the capital city wagodugu say the
president has been detained at a
military base soldiers have taken
control of the main tv station now this
all follows a day of unrest and
overnight gunfire near the presidential
home henry wilkins joins us now on the
line from the capitol uh
uh tell us where you are and what you're
seeing
yeah so we're outside the uh the
national television station rtb at the
moment uh the the building has clearly
been taken over by the the military
they've blockaded the entrance with an
armored vehicle and uh installed an
anti-aircraft gun
just outside there's been uh helicopters
circling for the for the last couple of
hours uh we're really just expecting a
uh an announcement from presumably the
uh the mutineers
uh who who began meeting yesterday in in
the capital
uh to say that the government has uh
have been taken over
is it possible to speculate as to
whether all the military is behind this
or is it a faction contained within the
military
it doesn't it seems at the moment that
it's uh it does seem to be quite unified
uh yesterday there was there was gunfire
throughout the city uh even into the uh
early hours of this morning but uh today
there appears to be a marked difference
uh in the way that the mutineers are
behaving yesterday they were wearing ski
masks and had their faces covered today
they're walking around quite confidently
with uh with their faces uncovered we're
not hearing any gunfire uh at the moment
across the city so it does appear that
uh there's been a unified military uh uh
coup
and uh
and this is progressing
there were those earlier reports of
protesters on the streets and this is
unusual because normally what happens
when there's a coup or an attempted coup
or a mutiny the local people protest
against
the coup plotters against the mutineers
but apparently these protesters were in
favor of the the coup
that's true so yesterday there uh some
protesters tried to gather of the
placebo
where many protests take place uh they
were quickly dispersed but conspicuously
they weren't dispersed by the military
they were discussed by the local police
uh with tear gas and so on so uh
certainly as of as of yesterday the the
police were not acting in unison with
the with the military but we certainly
haven't heard of anything uh like that
happening here today okay henry thank
you very much let's uh bring in nicholas
arc he joins us live now from dakar uh
nick just take us through what your
reading of this situation is
i mean this is really a situation that
president rockman
should have anticipated there's been
mounting protests against him remember
peter we talked about this on saturday
when there were protest ban protests a
peaceful ban protest uh that was bound
sorry by authorities um protesting
against the deteriorating security
situation in the country burkina faso
that's been facing a wave of attacks by
armed groups linked to isil and al-qaeda
and
pretty much the border areas of the
country are well the the authorities
have lost control in key areas
in the north and the east the area that
borders with mali and faced with that
millions of people have been fleeing
towards the capital which seems to be
the only safe place so there's been
mounting protests against the president
now he's taken some steps by uh by um
by dismissing his governments several
times in the past also replacing the
minister of defense but really uh the
court the ball is in his court and right
now what we're seeing is that the
military that had given them him an
ultimatum to try to change the situation
to give them more means that was the
main demands yesterday by the mutineers
um to give them more means to try to
fight this threat well they said if uh
the president didn't respond to their
demands that they would take over power
and that's what's happening right now
what's interesting to watch peter is
that this is happening in the country
burkina faso where the french forces are
present there was a joint patrol with
the burkina faso military earlier on
this week where a french soldier was
wounded they have their special forces
on the ground and it's unlikely that
they the french would support another
military takeover in the region there in
burkina faso peter and to put this into
context into a broader context i guess
for us nick this is not
a small country and there are large
areas of a medium to large-sized country
that were simply no-go areas for the
government and for the military as well
that's right it's a landlocked country
that shares borders with mali but also
key other uh nations in the area and and
for many years uh before this uh before
hawke mccabre was elected democratically
well we have to remember there was a
leader bless compadre who was there for
27 years and he kept that country safe
from attacks now what's interesting to
note where this mutiny started is in a
place where a key a key player general
gender a is being held he tried an
attempted coup in 2014 and he is known
as someone that has been speaking to
armed groups in the past that kept
burkina faso safe now he's being locked
in there in that camp there's also
someone that was arrested just last week
another member of the military there was
a commander in the north of the country
that was uh arrested allegedly
accused of a coup attempt against hakma
boy these are two key figures of the
military it's unclear if they have a
role in this situation but we have to
remember the context in which this is
happening three coups peter in the
region guinea now in the hands of the
military mali now in the hands of the
military and perhaps now burkina faso
there's a step back
in democracy in the region but for many
in burkina faso the military stepping in
is a step forward for more security for
them and for them to be able to finally
return home to
places that are in large swaths of areas
that are in the hands of armed groups
peter
nick thank you so much nicholas hark
there joining us live from senegal